ils ont répondu présent pour cette
rencontre importante les plaisirs oies
se sont imposé 29 à 27 face à marolles
une équipe redoutable qui pointait au
troisième rang du classement avant ce
match à égalité de points avec plaisir
une quatrième victoire de suite pour
l'équipe de victor garrigues et aura une
deuxième place et une deuxième place en
jeu donc voilà on est à égalité de
points avec marronne 6e gagne est
deuxième et le cinquième
ces propos ont donc voila et puis on
avait surtout à coeur de par notre
prestation à domicile travail si la
salle est très très costaud on sait très
bien préparé toute la semaine et on est
content ça paye trois points pour une
victoire pas évidente
un début de partie équilibré entre les
deux équipes marolles a mené pendant une
partie de la première mi temps puis la
rencontre bascule lorsque les plaisirs à
se retrouvent en supériorité numérique
on a fait 15 très très bonnes minutes en
fin de première mi temps on arrive à
passer devant et je pense qu'à partir de
ce moment-là psychologiquement on les a
atteint et on est revenu avec les mêmes
intentions début de deuxième
je pense qu'on a très bien exploité un
moment donné où ils ont décidé de jouer
un joueur de plus où on a on a pris le
choix tactiques de ne pas s'aplatir est
décédé quand la circulation
un choix tactique qui a permis à plaisir
de récupérer des ballons et de marquer
dans une cage vide plusieurs fois
couplée à une défense agressive sur les
dix mètres la recette plaisir oise pour
l'emporter sans plusieurs défensives
qu'on travaille depuis maintenant
sa quatrième saison on a on en tire bien
les ficelles et on sait agir là où on
doit agir
on sait agir là où les rapports de force
en notre faveur parce que maintenant on
va être attendu un peu partout et voilà
rien n'est joué cette saison on perd
deux matches on est huitième on en gagne
deux on est premiers donc voilà chaque
mois je vais très très important et
décisif en toute humilité les hommes de
victor garrigues et vont poursuivre le
travail à l'entraînement et prendre les
matches les uns après les autres avec
comme objectif de tous les remporter